Praise be to God,
praise [laughter] to God, praise be to God, praise be to God, praise be to God,
whatever He wants
Bless you
go ask
before the
why do you think that's a good
question why do you think Christianity is wrong that's a good question when God creates
us remember God creates us with the tr to recogn what is tr so to
tell me that
gods is God believes that God become a
baby which God is perfect time correct
so for God becing a baby that doesn't
make any sense because a baby created
is God created God  does whatever he
wishes accord to his wisdom but there's
difference between what God is what God does
what God does he does whatever he wishes
according to his wisdom what God is
doesn't change at all meaning he's always
perfect even in the Old Testament Lord
not a man that isah in a book of
numbers God is not a man i should mind
okay so when you look to the teaching of
christianity about Jesus be doesn't make
any sense what your name again
if i to hospital baby just came out
private woman full of blood and say your
god you  believe me are you so that's what
the t of jesus  isable even mary
Never believe that baby was good.  Jesus
himself never he was clearly because he
said I'm going to my have
a likewise about people die for
sins.  That's not the teaching of the old
testament at all.
Jeremiah Daniel Isaac none of them
believe that someone should sacrifice.
Yes, they have this animal sacrifice but
not for the animal taking all your sins.
Okay.  And the Bible clearly says you
should be responsible for your sins.  So
we can see there's many things within
Christianity which goes against our
universal knowledge doesn't make any
sense to us.
me telling something in Chinese and if
you don't follow in Chinese I punish you
I don't understand Chinese talking about
you see so how God tell us to believe
the most important thing but doesn't
make any sense to us Jesus is God but is
a son of god but he is God but is a son
of himself Jesus is God and he knows
everything but he didn't know the hour
Jesus is God but he has two nature man
and a good nature but Jesus as a man
always pray to the father he doesn't
know anything about his God  nature.
Even about the season doesn't make any
sense. Jesus himself was a Muslim. He said, "
I can't do anything by myself to God.
According to God's teaching,
I came to teach you God's way." There is no god
but
God,
and I
bear witness
that Muhammad is the Messenger of God. Praise be to
God.